good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van
horn from the university of virginia i am
proud to welcome you to this first edition of our
2021-2022 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health institute
of virginia the uva brain institute the college
of arts and sciences the school of data science
and through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences this year's theme
is ethical challenges of artificial intelligence
in biomedicine where we will enjoy presentations
on fridays from leading thinkers about the
promise opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical and
clinical sciences selected participants in
our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville virginia next
june applications for our biomedical data science
innovation lab program are being accepted until
january 31st 2022 so please consider applying
and or encouraging your junior colleagues to do
so we look forward to reviewing these application
materials it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our very first speaker in the series dr
renee cummings data activist in residence at the
university of virginia's school of data science
renee holds a master's degree in real
rehabilitation science and substance abuse
counseling from hunter college and masters of
arts and criminal justice from john jay college
and a master's certificate in terrorism studies
she designed her own bachelor's degree at hunter
college in political science philosophy media
studies and creative writing she is also a
community scholar in artificial intelligence and
criminal justice at columbia university renee is
an ai ethicist and she holds the awesome and very
cool title of being the very first data activist
in residence at the school of data science here at
uva she's been advocating for ai that we can trust
which is accountable transparent explainable
responsible and principled as was more diverse
equitable and inclusive she's been on the front
lines of all these different areas of ethical
ai she specializes in ai leadership policy
development governance risk management and
a number of other ways in which ai can be used to
save lives she's committed to using ai to empower
and transform the landscape of biomedicine of
politics of policy and many other areas of uh
of thought she is on the board of advisors for
the carnegie council for ethics and international
affairs and is the founding board member of the
springer journal ai ethics she is also on the
board of women and voice as well as on the board
of inspired minds producers of the world summit ai
and she lectures routinely and extensively on ai
and data ethics and contributing significantly to
ethical emerging technologies so not only are
we looking forward to what we expect to be a
awesome uh a seminar today from renee we are
excited to have her serving as a 2021 2022
biomedical data science innovation lab mentor so
our students and participants will be able to uh
interact with her directly at our in-person
meeting here in charlottesville next june
so to kick off our 2021-2022 biomedical data
science seminar series renee's lecture today
is going to be entitled data activism and the
imagination of biomedical data science this
lecture will touch on the importance of enhancing
diversity equity inclusion in health care through
data activism as well as showcase some of renee's
expertise from being at the front line of ethical
ai and data science as typical we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording by youtube
and if you are watching on youtube thank you for
joining us also our specially selected 2021-2022
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit any
questions for dr cummings by the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of dr cummings lecture
and with that welcome renee we are so excited
to hear from you and uh hear your lecture today
thank you so much jack and let me just tell you
it's just renee it's not dr cummings so thank you
for that fantastic introduction so greetings
everyone good afternoon it is such an honor
and thank you for this opportunity to be kicking
off this brilliant speaker series hosted by the
medical the biomedical data science innovation
lab featuring such forward-thinking minds and
data science artificial intelligence and ethics
curated under the leadership of the indomitable
indomitable professor extraordinaire jack
ben ward and his most efficient team it is
also such a privilege to be serving as one of
the mentors for the 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab where the theme is the
ethical challenges of artificial intelligence in
biomedicine the interdisciplinary component and
creative collaborations of clinical practice
through the biomedical data science innovation
lab through truly excite me and i look forward
to the experience as a mentor i believe our
mentorship is a reciprocal experience so
as i share with you i learned from you and know
that i appreciate you in this talk i've decided
to explore data activism and the imagination of
biomedical data science and the importance of
algorithmic justice and advancing social justice
in biomedical research over the last three years
i've been speaking a lot internationally about
stretching the imagination of ai through justice
diversity equity and inclusion what we are
called the jedi principle which is so critical
to my work because of its focus on the practice
and the policies of providing equal access to
opportunities and resources for people who might
otherwise be excluded or marginalized minoritized
groups high needs underserved under-resourced
communities individuals with disabilities
individuals who've been historically discriminated
against and naturally i chose data activism
because i am the first data activist in residence
at the school of data science at the university
of virginia and that also is quite an honor i'm
an ai ethicist a criminologist and a criminal
psychologist and therapeutic jurisprudence
specialist and my background in terrorism
studies and counter-terrorism have contributed
significantly to my experience in ai risk
management ai crisis management ai crisis
communication and working with business
leaders to help them communicate ethically about
the ai risks and building uh public confidence and
public trust in ai from c-suite to main street i
examine challenges such as detecting mitigating
and managing risks across the ai life cycle
de-biasing from design to deployment monitoring
and evaluating ai systems and bringing critical
and creative thinking to the ways in which we
think about risks and do vulnerability audits and
algorithmic impact assessments i'm always thinking
about ai governance and justice and equity
and diversity and inclusion which are critical
to the policies we create and those robust and
rigorous ethical guardrails that are required for
responsible and principled ai ai we can trust
so i spend a lot of time thinking about the
challenges to ai governance challenges within
the context of fairness and non-discrimination
privacy accountability transparency explainability
auditability safety and security and of course
black box opacity and how the lack of an inclusive
approach built on justice equity and diversity
and inclusion could undermine public trust and
public confidence in ai and these ethical risks if
undetected across the ai life cycle from design to
development often spiraled into crises that create
significant challenges to an organization
and that's when i'm usually called into an
organization to deal with what i call inspired or
ai inspired reputational damage and revenue loss
and regulatory backlash sometimes a criminal
investigation or a media attack or media
expose because of irresponsible ai or an ethical
approaches to ai approaches that diminish public
trust and public confidence however over the
last 12 months in my role as the data activist
in residence at the university of virginia
school of data science i've been focusing
on ways in which we can use data and algorithms
to make policing more accountable and and
more transparent my work at uva has seen the
creation of a public interest tech tool that
measures the algorithmic force being deployed
by law enforcement and this tool is critical
because it gives us an opportunity to bring
greater oversight to ai and it also gives us
an opportunity to ensure that the kinds of work
that we are doing in ai is really being done
for the benefit of all it is really critical
for us to start to think about ways in which
we are mitigating risk it's really critical for
us to start to think about ways in which uh data
discrimination and data bias are really informing
the things that we do it is uh because of the
kinds of reputational damages that we are seeing
in ai that we have really got to uh reimagine
so i advocate for justice oriented a by design
and uh ethical algorithmic solutions expanding the
imagination of ai and protecting public rights
and looking at public interest and just about
protecting the public against the the dangers
of ai and that lack of diversity ai that is not
inclusive and of course ai does not look like all
of us so criminology is the work that brought me
to ai i became extremely curious and concerned
about the risks and these uh risk assessment tools
and uh uh just different forms of algorithmic
decision-making tools that were being deployed
across the criminal justice system the the assault
what i call of algorithmic decision-making systems
on policing sentencing juvenile justice child
protection corrections of parole and public
safety algorithmic injustice and what some call
computerized racism in real time the problematic
use of data and the lack of representation
and the lack of respect for representation in
in the data some of the many challenges with
which we are faced uh when we think about
the ways in which data is being uh sort of
unleashed on society so data discrimination
data profiling data marginalization data
victimization the monetizing and weaponizing
of our our data but what is happening at the
intersection of ai and criminal justice is also
happening at the intersection of of ai and and
many other uh uh industries and sectors education
hiring lending mortgages credit including at the
intersection of ai and and healthcare so race
ethnicity data healthcare ai are creating some
unique challenges medical algorithms are failing
communities of color we have seen those headlines
biased ai can be bad for your health and also
deadly although ai hold great's promise in health
care and in improving our lives many health care
ai systems are biased and although ai has the
extraordinary potential to drastically improve
health care outcomes ai also has the potential
to amplify and exacerbate racial and social
inequality so we experienced several uh pandemics
during covet 19 including the pandemic of racism
and health care and we continue to experience how
ai encodes racial discrimination within medicine
and consistently leads to negative outcomes for
black and brown indigenous people of color and
there has there has been several calls in in
health care for the need to promote algorithmic
fairness for fair and equal health care we
need fair and bias free ai but can we achieve
bias-free ai when we have already experienced
the limitations of uh technical de-biasing
efforts so imagine the impact of bias ai or ai
that discriminates against uh black indigenous
people of color on health care outcomes you know
think misdiagnosed under diagnosed undiagnosed
missed diagnosis loss of trust continued mistrust
in in medicine in high needs and underserved and
under-resourced uh marginalized communities or
poorer healthcare outcomes for for some groups
so healthcare resource allocation challenges or
just uh the dangers of inaccurate data sharing
so how do we use bio medicine to future proof
healthcare how do we foster a healthy ai ecosystem
through biomedicine what systems should we install
through biomedicine to mitigate these harms and
long-term negative consequences of data on
society or ai on society how do we promote ethical
innovation in biomedical data science how do we
engender inclusive innovation in biomedical data
science or how do we use ai to save lives and
extend lives and protect lives and how can you
in your work remedy some of the many
disparities we are experiencing in ai
infused healthcare algorithmic injustices
continue to undermine the maturity and integrity
of many ai systems uh algorithmic injustices are
creating a trajectory of intergenerational trauma
harm inequalities and long-term negative impacts
on societies and on the the question of algorithms
we we hear so much about algorithms across
industries what's the power of an algorithm
how does this unseen categorical judgment inform
the lives of others how does an algorithm set the
agenda how does an algorithm assign priority how
does an algorithm shape the the context of our
decision making or influence behavior or how
does the technology we create shape the cultural
economic political social and environmental and
historic conditions under which we exist and how
does technology new and emerging technology
such as ai create and shape the conditions in
which others have got to exist and their quality
of life or how does an algorithm connect us or
disconnect us are we limiting the possibilities
of others through the technologies we create
are we prepared to question the question so ai is
super powerful and i'm very passionate about the
transformative power of ai ai's ability to create
extraordinary possibilities in every industry and
just about every aspect of our lives i'm very
excited about precision healthcare and ai's
potential to enhance enhance everything we do
if we get ai right but the social construction
of algorithms are presenting some very unique
challenges on how algorithms impact lives and
livelihoods and life chances and opportunities
and legacy so computational models you know
algorithms are being used to disenfranchise and
we've got to think about that and disempower and
to disinvest in our high needs and underserved and
already under resourced communities uh algorithmic
exclusion is real there is a fear of algorithmic
determinism the long-term political consequences
of data and society if not done ethically
could be devastating data is about power
data is about privilege and data is about
politics and data is wrapped up in the popular
predispositions and age-old stereotypes and agenda
data affects every aspect of our decision-making
data is capital in a data-driven society data how
it's collected how it's analyzed how it's used
many believe our data is our destiny our data is
our dna we have been warned i think significantly
by so many scholars in technology and ai and
and ethics about the debilitating effects and
impacts of data on society and on marginalized
and minoritized uh communities the oppressive
nature of data is no secret and daily we are
becoming more aware of how data and ai continue to
reinforce racial and gender bias i mean just look
around at our communities and you will see how
data is even used today to uphold uh segregation
and deny black indigenous people of color access
opportunities resources to to build wealth and
often to good health we have been adequately
schooled in the unjust data practices built
on systemic racism and while we appreciate
and celebrate the great benefits of data data
for good we also appreciate how data is used to
control how data reinforces structural racism
how data reinforces marginalization and how it
denies access and opportunities and if we take
our minds back and walk back into that historic uh
stream of consciousness from the very beginning of
data collection in the united states the first uh
census of 1790 enslaved people were not
counted and recorded as full individuals
but rather as three-fifths of one white man or
white woman and not until the ratification of the
14 amendment in 1868 where african americans fully
counted what does this history of race and data
say about our present and the future of data so
when we think about the use of data historically
to create policies of exclusion and segregation
and oppression we we think about the data power
brokers and the the data of the elites and the
the private companies that own the majority of
our data making our own data literally at times
inaccessible and we think about data to define who
is undesirable and data to define who is worthy of
credit or who is worthy of access and opportunity
wealth and success and and good health but we also
think about how can we use data science to correct
these inequities and how could we use data
science in particular biomedical data science to
address the wrongs what's the change that's
required and what data do we need to do the
work that needs to be done and to bring a justice
oriented and trauma-informed approach to ai that
is diverse equitable and inclusive so data in the
best interests of the public data for civic action
data to create technology for the advancement of
all i mean that is how we supposed to think moving
forward we cannot explain away uh systemic racism
or bias and discrimination from our data sets
but at the same time we cannot shy away from the
conversations that we need to have and we cannot
shy away from the creative and uh conflict and
intellectual confrontation that is required to
address race and data in ai we have got to be
intentional so there is an inherent hypocrisy
that we must confront with honesty in data and ai
to develop the integrity and data-driven systems
and decision-making systems are using algorithms
and we have got to speak openly and and honestly
about bias and discrimination and systemic
racism and and how something like race when it
comes to data shapes our our world view at every
intersection data we realize that the data is not
colorblind and coded political correctness will
not deliver the kind of action that's required
to bring the kind of change that's required to ai
ai must have integrity for it to display maturity
and to end the crisis of confidence in ai created
by bias and discrimination and systemic racism in
the data and we we have no choice to to do
what is right in real time so we must think
of data within the context of of civil rights
and consider concepts such as social justice and
racial justice and design justice and algorithmic
justice in biomedical data science because
these are mandatory to ensuring human rights and
civil liberties are protected and remain protected
and that is why data activism is so critical at
this moment and data activism offers a radical
and real-time rethinking of ethical ai it moves
us from a very passive and reactive position of
ethics to a a practical and proactive and a more
radical stance uh data activism to me is so much
more than its definition and it's defined simply
as which is not so simple using digital technology
and data politically and proactively to foster
change and what data activism does is it forces us
to stretch the ethical and creative imagination
of ai and bring a new and uh more dynamic approach
to the ways in which we operationalize ethics
in in real time as we build new and emerging
technologies such as ai so data activism raises
our our consciousness on issues such as oppression
and colonization and patronization and exclusion
and absence and invisibility and silence in our
data and data activism forces us to reimagine
our data futures together with all of us in it
expanding the range of experts and stakeholders
involved in in how we think about data and
how we think about ai and and how we engage in
interdisciplinary teams to find solutions to
reduce those hidden effects of algorithms the
racial economic and educational disparities that
are are really hidden in in our data set so the
future of data as well as the future of biomedical
data science is really eternal ethical
vigilance in his 1993 book moral imagination
mark johnson described moral imagination
as an ability to imaginately imaginatively
discern various possibilities for acting in a
given situation and to envision the potential
help and harm that are likely to result from
any given action so biomedical data science must
live in that ethical moment of which johnson
speaks and confront the changing nature of ai
and the evolving ethical questions that we are
faced with every day biomedical data scientists
are some of our most crucial decision makers and
architects of our digital future and the future
of society as we forge forward so how do you plan
to use data science and biomedical data science
to address and redress the negative impacts of
technology that have been felt disproportionately
on communities of color ethnic religious
minorities and other marginalized groups of
how do we use data science and biomedical
data science to recognize and to reconcile
a long and traumatic history of technologies
being designed and deployed to track trace
terrorize traumatize sometimes the most vulnerable
and how does that uh biomedical data science stay
culturally aware and culturally responsive and
culturally sensitive and culturally relevant
how do we include in biomedical data science those
who've been historically left out of the design
and process of of technologies in particular
new and emerging technologies such as ai and
how do we offer communities ownership ownership
in the technological tools to be designed uh by
biomedical data science an algorithm we've got
to think about it as these algorithms redefine
biomedical data science how do we ensure the
tools that we are creating these algorithmic
decision-making systems celebrate agency
and autonomy and democracy and empowerment
and self-actualization so while there are myriad
possibilities for discrimination and inequitable
treatment by ai in health care there are even
more exciting possibilities of ai are doing
amazing things in healthcare precision healthcare
just think of the extraordinary possibilities
but we must confront those identities that are
intertwined in our networks the network nature of
algorithmic discrimination and computational code
and design assumptions and cultural stereotypes
which often make a deadly combination when we
think of best practice health outcomes and also
remember what makes you uncomfortable is often
good for the soul so biomedical data science
has a great opportunity to rethink models of
discrimination and mechanisms for accountability
and transparency so in your work i ask you how
do you leverage the power and privilege you hold
to question existing norms and assumptions about
data and ai how do you defer to the expertise of
communities that best understand how technologies
have and continue to inflict harm on them
i was uh reading not too long ago and uh uh
some work from a professor of anthropology
at the university of virginia and i saw that he
is the director i don't know this is the current
position of the bioethics program at uva jared
zygon and he speaks about data science and he says
it's about world building and what kind of world
will you use data science to build and he adds
we are always in the process of or engaged
in the process of world building and we
have an ethical responsibility to think about
how and we create and what we create through
data science and through our actions this data
scientists and how these actions impact the world
and he adds that the inability to fully predict
does not free us from that responsibility
we must critically consider what kind of world
we are trying to create with data science because
it involves envisioning a better world and i will
ask you what is the world we are trying to create
through biomedical data science how will the
artifacts you create help change someone's
world how do we imagine a better world through
biomedical data science and how will the systems
you create interact with the world and impact the
world how will the systems you create shape the
legacies that we are able to create how do the
systems that you create shape the kind of life
we are going to to live and we're going to have
and how will we as society measure your legacy
the legacy you have created in biomedical or
through biomedical data science what will others
achieve through your work and i will finally
and i will ask you my last question would be
how will you be remembered and how will biomedical
data science be remembered i thank you very much
for the opportunity to engage you renee that was
just such a fantastic uh lecture um you covered
so many topics and it's all so important and uh
sorry you need to take a little moment there to
to uh get some water but i'm so glad that you're
able to to rally and uh continue to explain what
are so many different important topics i want to
ask you a few questions some from myself as i was
thinking about what you were saying and some that
have been contributed by some of our participants
the whole issue of trust seems to be fundamental
to the understanding of how um these algorithms
and and from ai can be applied in biomedicine
whether they're for diagnosis or treatment options
or what have you and we're very as you mentioned
we're very aware of the biases that have crept in
and those are very newsworthy that trust aspect
seems to be so critical to this and i know that
um for a lot of people in the um uh communities of
color that participation in research or basically
sharing their personal data is something they're
not they don't necessarily have much trust in the
system about how that data is going to be used
this produces kind of some data inequities where
just the data that we collect just doesn't have
the representation that would help us to kind of
incorporate those elements and reduce biases so
how do we how can we solve that how can we kind
of project ourselves as being trustworthy partners
instead of you know this kind of one directional
give us your data um so we can try and sell you
stuff or you know what i'm not articulating it
well but basically how can we encourage people to
be better participants as well as um ethicists in
this process thank you thank you for the question
and i think it really speaks to to to to who who
biomedicine data science is as a as a discipline
and the kind of work that's required because
it's about stakeholder engagement and it's about
uh community engagement but i also think it's
about changing the approach and not going into the
communities uh with the the concept that you're
just there to get the information and and take
that into information for for your benefit it's
really finding ways and this is the challenge that
we're seeing across the board even now through
ai ethics and public interest technology and how
do we get communities involved in the design and
development of technology so it really is going
to uh demand much more effort and it's going to
demand new and more creative ways of thinking
about stakeholder engagement and and how do we
bring our people to the uh you know proverbial
table that we speak about to get that level
of participation me i've been reading a lot about
value sensitive design and then you know and more
thinking about design justice and thinking about
ways in in which we could really bolster or give
stakeholder engagement a charge because in uh one
of my old existences i you know i i i worked as a
crisis uh communicator and working with
organizations at the the c-suite level to
deal with uh crises in in their various public so
i would say that community engagement has got to
be reimagined i would say that we've got to look
at other approaches i've say that we've got to uh
respect communities as producers of knowledge not
just producers of data and i think if we take that
approach it is going to benefit us in the long
run because we've got to defer to communities as
experts and i think we we we have not really done
that we often say that that is the approach that
we want to take but we do not uh deploy that kind
of approach and it really is about empowering
and sometime in the empowering there needs to
be demystifying and educating because sometimes
it is the time uh we have time constraints and
in those time constraints we need to get the
information that we we want and we want to get
it now but i think uh we've got to look at that
process again because uh we all know that you know
trust is something uh once it's gone you can't buy
it back you you know it takes really long to build
sometimes it's impossible to build it but we know
that we have big things to do in healthcare and in
disciplines like you know biomedical data science
that requires the expertise of these communities
and to get that it requires trust so if we start
to look at our communities as knowledge producers
and just not as data points i think that may be a
great place to start that's a great great
way to to answer that thank you so much
several of our participants were asking about that
if you could maybe elaborate a little bit more on
the jedi principle and how are organizations or
programs or technologies uh actually are they
achieving any of those principles certainly so
the jedi is just the acronyms for justice equity
diversity and inclusion and how critical that
is to ai maturity because uh the challenges
we have seen in ai are challenges created
because of a lack of appreciation for such
issues such as justice and criminal justice
we deployed all these algorithmic decision
decision making uh uh systems uh within
you know the context of using these risk
assessment tools to bring more efficiency and
effectiveness and expediency to the ways in which
justice is administered and what we realize
is that these tools were disproportionately
uh you know deploying uh sentences longer
sentences to to black and brown people
um uh i think uh ai is realizing that uh the days
for ethics washing or window dressing or ethical
fear have come to an end and there are some
things that have just got to be done in real time
uh to bring the requisite levels of maturity
and integrity that this technology needs to
really build more public confidence and to build
more public trust so i think organizations and
agencies and then we can see uh just even coming
out of the white house recently this whole call
for uh coming uh deploying a bill of rights
to deal with the ways in which we engage with
with algorithms you know saying that the original
social contract has probably expired and we didn't
think about algorithms how many hundreds of years
ago and how ai and technology is just changing our
relationship because one of the things uh you've
recognized about an algorithmic decision-making
system is how it can remove agency and remove
the ability to put the individual back into the
decision-making process and and these things
are so critical so when it comes to to let's
just say criminal justice you have an algorithmic
decision-making system that is able to undermine
uh procedural justice or due process so you have
someone who's been incarcerated who's ready for
parole and who's consistently denied parole until
that individual had to take the company the vendor
to court to uh really get into the black box to
see what was what were the data points that were
saying that they were not worthy of parole after
this individual did uh 15 years of solid time and
was an exemplary uh among uh you know the
the incarcerated and and was ready to be
uh you know reintegrated in society and ready
to return so when we think about justice when we
think about equity and we think about diversity
and inclusion it really brings uh to me uh uh
you know uh an approach that is so critical
because without those things what you get is a
very immature and irresponsible technology that
like ai that if it delivers only delivers in the
short term and then you start to get all of these
crises that need to be dealt with so they are so
critical because uh you know data activism is
is like you know fighting for civil rights and
your digital rights are critical and i think more
and more people are starting to realize that you
know uh rights need to be protected and while a
lot of people are still not you know ahead of the
class when it comes to understanding the long-term
impacts of the technology i think those of us who
are in those positions or who have the power and
the privilege and the opportunity need to do the
work that that is required so uh you know i cannot
uh overemphasize the importance of that jedi
principle in your work in biomedical data science
because social justice and algorithmic justice and
design justice are so critical to data science
well i i've mentioned at the beginning about
your title of data activist in residence here at
the at the school of data science uh here at uva
which is a wonderful title and clearly from your
presentation today you are indeed a data activist
and you know it dated activism i could just see
how it touches on things like politics and on
education and on you know social well-being um but
it's just so important in in science and certainly
healthcare as well what can we do to bring more
data activists like yourself with you know people
of color people from indigenous populations
basically into you know to the to the table
as scientists um you know it would be wonderful
to have more you know practicing scientists or or
physicians or clinicians part of this conversation
what can we do better to attract their interests
well i think it also and what we're realizing more
and more in science is that scholars are starting
to realize that uh maybe this uh sort of a
dispassionate view in which we had in the past uh
can no longer be uh relevant that something like
ai we're realizing cannot mature without emotional
intelligence and science cannot mature and develop
and continue to develop without that level of
emotional uh you know intelligence as well i
think what we can do is realize that in our work
uh wherever we stand in the lab or wherever
we stand in you know the across the healthcare
ecosystem that that we are leaders and that we
are advocates in our own work and we have got to
uh build our own consciousness and we build our
consciousness thinking about ways in which we
are to remain uh ethically vigilant and thinking
about justice and equity and diversity as a sort
of due diligence framework in how we uh deliver
and thinking about duty of care and if we think
about duty of care then we understand that we've
got to include that jedi principle in that uh you
know sort of duty of care approach and and in
doing that we've got to really again i think
what ai is doing is just challenging
our creativity on so many levels because
now we we've got to think about
how do we demystify this technology
how do we uh engage more uh young people of color
into the the conversation how do we go into those
communities because much of the technologies that
are being designed are being designed to use in
all our communities and if you're not going to get
that buy-in then you're going to be developing and
designing and deploying things and you're going
to be wasting a lot of resources so i think what
we've got to do is really uh popularize or uh
you know the conversation and we do that by uh
ensuring that at every level of the education
system we're having conversations about ai and
data i always say that ai is is our new language
it's our language of choice right now we've got to
be literate and for us to be literate we've got
to ensure from the earliest stages our children
are being exposed to this technology understanding
the implications understanding the excitement of
the technology and the great things that we can
do with it but understanding those great things
have got to come with an ethical push and if we
are to combine that sort of ethical early ethical
vigilance what we are also doing is creating a
certain high levels of ethical resilience as we
move into the design and the deployment so it's
about really exciting communities it's about uh
just going into those communities so having
the conversations and if we can go into the
communities bring those communities into our
spaces and into our labs so they can have that
experience as well i love that um you know the
the fundamental thread i'm detecting and you can
shoot me down if i'm incorrect is that it's
really education and communication um which
is so vital and there are a lot of physicians who
are really looking towards ai biomedical tools as
basically to help them make clinical decisions
um and it may be involving people of color or
women um who you know may not be quite represented
in the to the algorithm and how can we make sure
that um physicians who are trying to make these
very life and death decisions probably in a
matter of seconds uh understand the strengths
but also the limitations of biomedical ai tools
well definitely and because the decision
making is so high stakes and because
uh you know ai infuse our medical uh tools are are
so critical as you said it's about life and it's
it's about death and this is why we need
that ethical understanding this is why
we need to to to build those levels of ethical
resilience and this is why in just about every
sector we need to have that ethical understanding
and it's so critical for us to understand about
the power and the privilege and the politics and
data and for us to understand we cannot take the
data at face value and for us to understand when
a third party vendor creates something and and
delivers it to us we have certain questions that
we still need to ask so it really is about um
there's an extraordinary amount of comfort uh
that you you sense when people uh believe that
you know uh you know the data sets in neutral or
uh you know the things that we're using here uh
you know are are scientific and they're clinical
and they and they are just uh really uh very
neutral and those are fallacies and i think we've
all heard uh you know that there is no raw data
there is no raw data set so it really speaks
for it speaks to a kind of conscious raising
that has had that must happen as well in
medicine and in biomedical data science and it's
really about pushing that ethical approach to the
ways in which we design and develop and deploy
new and emerging technologies such as ai and it's
about being eternally vigilant because so much is
changing at such speed and in such scale with this
technology and we know that the law always lags
behind technology but we also know that we don't
need the law to do the right thing and we also
know that there are so many things that we need to
do in real time and this is why we want to always
ensure we are thinking about justice and equity
and diversity and inclusion and we are thinking
about how do we exist always in that ethical
moment and we are thinking about the fact that
this technology could not be perfect because it's
being designed by us and we are not perfect and
always thinking about how do we improve you
know whatever that technology is whatever the
outcomes are supposed to be so it really is about
pushing forward and pushing hard and an ethical
ai and responsibly and you know trustworthy ai
and understanding for us to do that we've all
got to be involved in the process it's just not
some designing for all but it has got to be all
uh really consulting and engaging in
in that design and deployment process
we're going several institutions are around the
country of developing undergraduate curricula in
data science and with biomedicine
being a major component of that
do you envision that our next generation of data
scientists who are you know in school now is there
an opportunity there to kind of like instill some
of the jedi principles into them as you know as
part of their education so it just becomes a
natural thing instead of somebody having to
you know be brought up to date they just know
it is there an opportunity there i think it's a
huge opportunity and i think we've got to jump at
it i think we're actually going a little too slow
and i think not only including the jedi principle
but bringing concepts such as data activism and ai
advocacy into the mix because we've got to
understand that you know this is a new and
emerging technology it's not you know uh it's it's
something that's developing every day and then
all of those views and experiences and and uh need
to be a part of the ways in which we think about
the technology and the ways in which we design so
i think we really need to move to move swiftly and
i think there's so much that we can do when it
comes to uh really educating data scientists and
and really making sure really ensuring
that they get an education that is is
is really uh dynamic and really reflects who we
are renee i think that uh this has just been an
absolutely fascinating discussion i thank you
so much for giving us so much to think about
um at the intersection of ethics ai and just
really what these these important challenges
are as we begin this conversation we're going
to be having throughout the year and we're going
to look forward to having you meeting with our um
biomedical data science innovation lab fellows as
a mentor and sharing further some of your thoughts
about this very important space i want to remind
everybody that applications for our biomedical
data science innovation lab program are still
being accepted up until january 31st of 2022 so we
look forward to you uh yourselves um applying or
encouraging your other junior colleagues or junior
colleague associates to um to apply and we look
forward to being able to review those applications
so that uh maybe you or your colleagues would have
an opportunity to uh meet with renee in person
and discuss these very important topics and
with that i want to thank everybody for joining
us today and i especially want to thank renee
for just a fantastic uh discussion
of just this hugely important area
really challenging us to think differently about
data activism using our imaginations and how we
apply them to biomedical data science so thank
you so much renee thank you very much and thank
you everybody for joining us have a wonderful
weekend we'll look forward to seeing you next week